-How are you, Sarah?
-I'm well, thank you.
How are you?
-I am well, too.
It's so lovely to see you,
and congratulations on the show.
But more importantly,
congratulations.
I heard you just got a dog
-I did get a dog.
But I only got a dog,
because I can't have your dog.
-[ Laughs ]
-And that's really the truth
I have a video of your dog
that I took once
when I ran into your dog,
and it's something I look at
I might look at it, like,
once a week, at least.
-It was a very big deal,
and it's very nice to hear that,
because I don't know if you know
this very true thing.
My friend Andy Samberg think
my dog is an ugly rat monster.
And so it's very nice
to have someone on the sho
who is sort of supporting an
singing the praises of Frisbee
-Frisbee is
the greatest dog ever
and beautiful beyond measure
like a fawn and a baby dee
in the woods,
so Andy Samberg actually doesn't
know what he's talking about
-Yeah. And I think anybody
watching the show would realiz
that you are a person of taste
whereas he is a gutter dweller
-I'm gonna vote yes
on that, as well.
I don't know the guy,
but I'm gonna say yes.
-So you -- you're an executive
producer of this show, as well
And one of the things
that means is,
you have to watch it
as you are making it.
And I know from our histor
that you do not particularly
like watching yourself on film
so how was that transition
into watching dailies?
-I became, like, a vorac--
It was, like,
at lunch every day,
I was, like, in the traile
with, like, popcorn, just like
"All right, all right,
all right, that was good,
that was bad, that wasn't good."
E-mailing the producer going
you know,
"Please don't use take 6.
Can you push in on 7?"
I mean, I became, like,
an absolute nut. Nut.
-But this is sort of --
This arced.
Because, in the beginning
of your career,
you would watch yourself.
But then, I guess,
"People Versus O.J. Simpson"
is the one that you famously
have not watched, correct?
-Yeah, I think in the beginning,
I was so excited that people
were actually letting me do it
that I was like, "Look!"
You know, I would just -- it was
really kind of crazy to me
Not that it isn't anymore.
I'm not saying it's, like,
old hat or anything, Seth.
I'm just saying --
It's just, you know,
the O.J. Simpson thing,
and this is gonna be
a really exceedingly actress
thing to say, but, you know,
I had a very profound experience
making it, where I almost
didn't know where I stoppe
and Marcia began.
And this happens to a lot of
very serious actors.
I'm sure you've talked
to a lot of them.
And so I didn't want to see it
because I thought this was
a profoundly special thing
And then, a lot of people
seemed to think it was good,
and then I was like,
"Well, now I'm really
not gonna watch it for fear that
I will think they're all idiots,
and what if I hated it?"
It just felt too precious to me.
-I think that's the right wa
to play it, genuinely.
Especially because
everyone has said,
myself included,
it's so perfect.
Like, as a performer,
you would just --
even if you found
one or two imperfections,
it would then
lessen your value of it.
-Believe me, I would find many
Marcia was left-handed,
she had been a dancer,
so she walked
in a particular way,
and I thought,
they're gonna use a take -
that was back
before I was watching dailies,
where I probably picked up
something with my right hand
and nobody was paying attentio
to that the way that I was
so I thought, "This is
gonna be a disaster for me."
But, Sterling K. Brown --
you gotta say the "K."
Every time I see him, he's like,
"Have you really? Not yet?
And I'm like, "No."
And he's like, "Do you think
you're ever, I mean ever?
And I was like, "It's been
like five years now.
Now I really don't think
I'm gonna do it."
And he's like,
"I think you really should."
But I'm not --
I don't think I'm going to
-Well, let's see.
Let's see how long it take
for TV production
to start up again,
because you might have
to go back
and watch everything
that was ever made before.
-[ Laughs ]
-Okay, okay, fine.
-So this is sort of a differen
challenge where you're taking on
a fictional character,
Nurse Ratched,
that we know from
"Cuckoo's Nest,"
one that we have seen, and w
feel like we know from the film.
How did you -- playing a
character in prequel,
that has been, obviously,
played before,
to great acclaim --
how did you approach that?
-Well, I mean, she won
an Academy Award
for that performance,
so it really begs the question
about, you know, how sane am I
that I would think
that would be a good idea
to maybe see
if there was anything else
I could parse that she didn't,
you know, bring to the table
But I just, you know,
I watched the performance,
and I tried as much as I could
to steal everything I coul
from Louise Fletcher
and just sort of
pretend it had been
my invention.
I think that's usually
the best way to do it
if you're going to be
creating some backstory.
And the good news is,
we invented the whole thing,
so we could kind of say
that anything goes.
'Cause there was nothing
in the book, nor in the movie,
about her life
outside that hospital,
so we were free to do
anything we wanted,
and, boy,
did we take liberty with that.
-Also, years from now,
if somebody decides to watch i
in sort of narrative order
and start with the prequel
it will look like
Louise stole from you.
-You know,
I did have this thought.
-[ Laughs ]
-I'm just...
-You are always
so many steps ahead.
-It was part of my master plan
that you know --
your Donald Trump impression -
Can I just state,
for the record?
-Yes.
-I think it bests Alec Baldwin
I really do. I mean,
I know this is sacrilegious.
I know this is NBC.
I know we all love --
I mean, I love Alec.
I think he's a --
You have no accoutrements.
I like to say "accoutrements."
-Yeah.
-You're not having any help.
It's a very special --
very special impression.
-I don't like the man,
but he does speak through me
-He really does.
There's, like, a weird --
Talk about not knowing where you
begin and someone else --
Whatever it is.
But yeah.
-Like when I come home at night,
some nights Alexi's like,
"Hey, you've got to leave
Donald Trump at the door."
-"You've got to leave
Donald Trump in the workplace.
[ Both laugh ]